[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce livre spécial qui est
une carte blanche donnée aux étudiants
de Master 2 de recherche et création
littéraires de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin qui vont nous
parler des livres qu'ils ont choisi de
mettre à l'honneur avec ragnanouille
bonjour
vous êtes donc étudiant en Master 2
voilà ambre de benets bonjour
et puis liant le marchand bonjour alors
on se connaît bien maintenant ça fait
trois fois quand même
l'habitude c'est la deuxième fois donc
nous sommes des habitudes
on va parler peut-être un instant parce
que vous voulez présenterez plus plus
avant ensuite des livres que vous avez
choisi mais
comment c'est fait le choix
Rania vous allez devoir de roman qui
s'appelle ou pas l'aiguille comment
s'est fait ce choix c'était
vous avez étudié dans vos études que
vous avez choisi
c'était d'abord un cadeau de ma mère et
oui et ensuite je l'ai relu récemment
grâce au séminaire de madame barjonnais
qui était sur les récits d'enquêtes donc
ça m'a ça m'a rappelé
la joie que j'avais eu en disant oui je
l'ai relu et donc
moi c'est en fait un choix coup de cœur
j'ai découvert ce livre
quand j'étais au lycée et ça a été un
coup de foudre pour moi un crédit et il
m'a pas quitté je l'ai relu de
nombreuses fois
ça s'appelle le pavillon des enfants
fous et on verra une histoire d'abord
réelle
et qui est très très forte
cela dit où passe-lui aussi l'histoire
extrêmement forte et puis Lilian alors
vous avez vous avez choisi la plus
secrète des mémoires des hommes qui est
le prix goncourté en quoi 2021
et je l'ai lu cette année-là justement
aussi et c'était pour moi aussi un choix
coup de cœur enfin c'est un livre que
j'ai vraiment beaucoup apprécié dès la
première lecture donc est-ce qu'il y a
des livres comme ça dit notre vie n'est
plus tout à fait la même après qu'avant
est-ce qu'il y a des choses qui volent
changer un peu oui
on a l'impression de enfin après ma
lecture j'avais vraiment l'impression
d'avoir
fait l'expérience de toute une vie
plutôt que de juste avoir lieu un livre
et de pouvoir passer à autre chose
lecture vous étiez plus petit que Lyon
non du tout je suis d'accord avec les
filles clairement des livres que j'ai lu
qui m'ont vous avez en avant et après la
lecture
non pas tous
alors on va commencer
avec vous Rania oui avec donc où passe
l'aiguille de Véronique Mougin
est un roman de Véronique aux gens donc
qui dit oui
en 2019 aux éditions J'ai Lu et c'est ce
qui est intéressant c'est que elle
aurait pu en faire une biographie parce
que c'est inspiré de de la vie des
souvenirs de son cousin qui a réellement
vécu à la durée voilà c'est inspiré de
faire mais choisi de
d'accentuer ce côté romanesque de la vie
tout simplement exceptionnelle de son
cousin elle a choisi d'en faire un roman
mais il y a un réel travail d'enquête
elle le dit elle-même elle a vraiment
disséquer les archives c'est rendu au
camp de concentration il y a quelque
chose vraiment il y a un travail
important très conséquent derrière et
voilà enfin elle raconte donc l'histoire
de de son cousin oui voilà il était
adolescent donc il était âgé de 14 ans
surnommé Tony et voilà elle raconte son
parcours le avant le pendant le après la
déportation
au printemps 1944 et après on a tous
alors il me semble qui a été ça se passe
en Hongrie oui voilà et il a je crois
que c'était déporté si je ne montrais
pas au courant
[Musique]
et voilà il
est juif il est oui
et c'est justement enfin je pense que
c'est c'est la façon dont se démarque
ce livre des autres récits et
témoignages de guerre c'est justement
parce que parce qu'il est présenté à
travers le regard d'un adolescent oui
donc
il est très désobéissant très têtu oui
voilà enfin c'est chaud voilà c'est
c'est quelqu'un qui est drôle évidemment
très drôle
et c'est enfin c'est ce qu'elle disait
d'ailleurs dans une interview enfin ce
n'est pas ce qu'on voit d'habitude par
exemple avec ce qu'on a des enfants
des récits d'enfants de guerre par
exemple avec Anne Frank c'est
complètement différent c'est quelqu'un
qui n'écoute pas qui a du mal
justement prendre les conseils voilà
c'est c'est compliqué
mais justement c'est ce qui lui permet
d'incarner le mieux cette idée de guerre
d'opposition à l'autorité autant au
gouvernementale que familial et
au brigade à l'héritage autant des
passions que de la vocation parce que
son père justement ou passer lui est
ailleurs pour homme alors voilà pourquoi
vous passez
lui parce que son père est et d'ailleurs
pour homme et il veut voir Tommy devenir
d'ailleurs à son tour mais il refuse
catégoriquement il veut devenir entre
autres espions et à la fin ils se
rencontrent ironiquement que c'est la
couture qui va lui permettre de survivre
en compte de concentration oui voilà
c'est les les uniformes non c'est ça
c'est parce qu'en fait ce sont les
tailleurs qui sont le plus demandé et
donc ils voient pas forcément exterminés
des médecins qui sont tués en premier
enfin et entre autres et lui avec son
père qui sont ailleurs il réussissent à
son père lui dit la couture c'est ce qui
le nourrit et l'habit donc ça lui permet
d'avoir toujours un uniforme propre
enfin son trou voilà et aussi il arrive
à les changer contre d'autres choses au
marché noir donc c'est ce qui lui permet
de survivre et enfin j'avais lu quelque
part une critique qui disait justement
que la couture dans ce livre c'était un
peu le fil rouge de de son histoire de
la vie de Tony parce que parce que
vraiment c'est ce qui va le suivre après
après le compte de concentration et qui
va lui permettre d'apprécier la vie
parce que ça va devenir une passion pour
lui et une passion qui va être beaucoup
plus puissante que celle de son père
donc
le roman va jusqu'à quelle époque
alors il va
parce que Tommy a vécu longtemps il a
vécu vraiment très longtemps par contre
ils étaient très contents il me semble
j'avais lu il était très content pour
pour Véronique mon genre d'avoir pu lui
dire ce livre mais qu'il a refusé de
l'accompagner dans ses recherches quant
à la voyager
il ne voulait pas retourner là-bas
accepter de raconter mais son plus
donc
c'est vrai que c'est un roman
extrêmement fort quoi parce que ça nous
plonge dans la dans cette période
terrible
avec un avec en effet un personnage qui
va se dire il y a de l'humour il y a de
l'humour c'est justement ça c'est ce qui
m'a le ce qui m'a plu vraiment dans ce
livre c'est déjà le style d'écriture de
Véronique aux gens et la manière dont tu
as réussi à notamment parce que nous
n'avons pas seulement le point de vue de
Tony bien sûr c'est le narrateur
principal mais il y a aussi beaucoup de
passages qui sont racontés entre les
chapitres donc par la perspective
d'autres des personnages qui rencontrent
tout en ton parcours et donc ça nous
permet d'avoir une sensation de densité
de la vie de Tony exactement on voit
vraiment que c'est une c'est quelque
chose de réel et que les émotions que ça
nous fait ressentir c'est la réalité en
fait justement ça aurait pu être un
récit ou enfin et c'est un roman
qu'est-ce qui en fait un roman justement
qu'est-ce qui est il y a des choses qui
sont inventées qui sont alors bien sûr
c'est c'est compliqué pour elle de
tout d'écrire avec enfin de d'écrire les
pensées bien sûr de des personnes que
rencontrer par par son cousin avec
précision donc elle se permet aussi
c'est moins d'inventer plusieurs choses
plus c'est il s'agit plus de d'accentuer
oui parce que c'est vrai qu'elle a pas
pu voilà mais oui mais enfin tout a été
il me semble elle a dû demander bien sûr
la cohérence
plus vrai que le récit
très bien merci merci beaucoup Rania
on continue avec vous Lilian le marchand
la plus secrète
des hommes en effet donc
oui déjà le titre est extrêmement je
l'ai beaucoup aimé c'est ce qui m'a
aussi
donné interpeller la première fois que
je l'ai vu et donc c'est le prix
Goncourt de 2021 il a été publié la même
année
c'est un roman qui suit qui suit diegan
c'est un auteur qui a publié récemment
enfin ça se passe en 2018 il a publié
récemment un recueil de poésie si je ne
dis pas de bêtises
qui s'appelle l'anatomie du vide et en
faisant des recherches pour ses études
il trouve un traité de littérature qui
parle de TC et limande c'est un auteur
un auteur sénégalais sachant que jigan
vient également du Sénégal qui a écrit
lui le labyrinthe de linhumain
oui si tu dis pas de bêtises
et donc du coup voilà
et ensuite après le donc il ce roman Le
Labyrinthe de l'inhumain et
à totalement disparu oui vraiment
totalement disparu il reste un exemple
il reste un exemple mais voilà je tiens
pas plus
qui circule un peu de main et voilà
parce que ce roman a fait scandale en
fait à ça à sa sortie en 1938 notamment
déjà par rapport au racisme de l'époque
mais aussi parce que ce roman reprend
ouvertement des phrases d'autres romans
et même
si c'est un vrai une vrai oeuvre
qu'il a écrit
thématique qui m'a beaucoup intéressé
dans ce dans ce sens
d'avoir cette limite entre
la référence oui voilà la référence et
le plagiat et ce qu'on considère comme
étant une de l'interteualité où vraiment
un plage capture et dur et donc du coup
diegan va vraiment l'auteur a lui aussi
totalement disparu de la scène
littéraire dès que dès que son roman
fait scandale et donc diegan va partir
dans le monde entier à la recherche à la
recherche des fins sur les traces de
l'auteur pour
pour trouver des réponses aux questions
qu'ils se posent parce que ça fait
vraiment des années qu'il a entendu
parler de ce livre et qu'il veut la voir
mais qui n'arrive pas à le trouver vu
qu'il est vraiment nulle part et donc
oui voilà donc ça comme dit ça me fait
ça traite beaucoup de la limite entre
donc
l'Inter sexualité le plagiat mais ça
parle aussi beaucoup de évidemment de
racisme de l'immigration du rapport
entre du rapport avec le pays d'origine
et la famille quand on est dans un pays
totalement différent de nos de nos
parents
mais et ça parle aussi beaucoup de
l'impact de la colonisation sur les pays
africains notamment le du côté du côté
de la langue le l'imposition le fait que
le français soit imposé tout ce genre de
choses et ce que j'ai vraiment aussi
beaucoup aimé avec ce livre
c'est qu'il est particulièrement
déconcertant mais il reste vraiment très
très captivant aussi en même temps c'est
personnellement j'ai vraiment eu
l'enquête c'est aussi ce qui est c'est
ça
oui exactement
qu'est-ce que c'est le mystère de la
création aussi de l'oeuvre littéraire
aussi parce que justement c'est aussi
une des thématiques de ce livre est
aussi de
savoir ce qu'on fait une fois qu'on a
vraiment réussi à publier
le livre sur lequel on travaillait et
est-ce qu'on continue ou est-ce que on
arrête et ça ça c'est quelque chose qui
me parle aussi évidemment
mais oui donc voilà on sent qu'il y a
vraiment un très très gros travail dans
le style dans la forme du roman
dans la conception du roman lui-même et
dans le personnage principal aussi qui
est particulièrement attachant et ce qui
aide vraiment à le rendre attachant et à
nous faire nous identifier à ce
personnage c'est qu'il est le narrateur
aussi du livre et
donc oui voilà c'est
en soi personnellement je quand j'ai lu
le livre j'ai compris pourquoi elle
avait gagné le Prix Goncourt dès le
premier tour vraiment dès le début je me
suis dit ça c'est on sent que je sais
plus contre qui c'était
en 2021 ça a été très serré et ça a été
contesté
mais en 2021 oui je crois que j'ai pas
beaucoup contestation mais non il a été
élu au premier tour dans tous les cas
donc à l'unanimité à l'unanimité
dès le début et franchement en ayant lu
le livre je comprends pourquoi les uns
les autres vous vous aimerez vous
décidez une carrière d'écrivain vous
aussi on espère
le un prix comme ça parce que
grâce à n'était pas très connu quand il
est Goncourt
vous en rêveriez comme ça d'avoir un
prix comme le Goku
la concrétisation de la carrière en ce
moment la reconnaissance d'abord
un vrai travail qui vient derrière la
création
merci beaucoup donc la plus secrète mais
moi des hommes et on va passer avec vous
on devenait
celui que s'appelle le pavillon des
enfants fous de Valérie Valère
stock
c'est important de dire parce que
il y a eu des problèmes avec des
éditeurs
[Musique]
donc déjà Valérie Valère faut savoir que
c'est un pseudo elle s'appelle en
réalité Valérie Samana et en fait elle
est née en 1961 et elle est morte en
1982 assez tragiquement elle s'est
suicidé complètement en fait elle ne
voulait pas du tout vivre et c'est
justement en fait voilà c'est ça et
c'est le c'est le roman en fait fin son
autobiographie de cette partie là qui
l'explique
puisqu'en fait elle a passé plus enfin
elle a passé deux ans en hôpital
psychiatrique pour anorexie mental et en
fait elle en est ressorti extrêmement
traumatisé
en fait et en fait elle écrit
elle ressort comme ça vraiment marqué
elle avait très en quand elle a été
internée deux ans plus tard elle on sort
assez difficilement il faut le dire
c'est même c'est c'est lourd à lire à
certains moments on sent vraiment toute
cette
ce cri du coeur cette cette
détermination qu'elle a en fait à ne pas
vivre du tout elle refuse de s'alimenter
elle veut pas et en fait c'est même dès
les premiers chapitres on sent qu'il y a
une ambiance assez particulière mais
c'est moi ce qui m'a beaucoup captivé
surtout enfin ça a piqué ma curiosité
j'ai voulu en savoir plus j'ai voulu
savoir comment ça se terminait et en
fait à la fin on se rend compte on se
rend compte que
la partie n'est pas tout à fait gagner
d'avance
aussi qu'elle est morte peut-être que ça
joue dans la façon dont on lit oui je
pense que
j'ai découvert après parce que je savais
pas à la lecture du tout en fait donc je
pensais qu'elle s'en était sorti et
quand je l'ai appris je me suis dit
tiens
c'est pas tout à fait anodin finalement
quand on lit et qu'on découvre ça c'est
vrai que c'est voilà qui livre le
publier
elle parle donc de la violence
hospitalière
beaucoup de cruauté beaucoup de enfin
c'est très forcé
elle veut mourir en fait son but c'est
elle ne veut pas vivre elle refuse et
elle a une anorexie mentale et c'est
pour ça qu'elle veut pas et que sa mère
en fait la colle entre guillemets dans
cet hôpital et en fait elle va toujours
refuser elle va même justement montrer
aussi le monde des hommes très cruels
même au niveau de la parentalité en fait
où elle considère que sa mère est un
monstre de ne pas la comprendre de ne
pas vouloir en fait la laisser mourir de
respecter son souhait en fait qu'elle sa
mère veut qu'elle livre et voilà c'est
toujours très compliqué en fait il veut
forcément
une non communication
absolument incompréhension totale entre
entre les parents et les enfants enfin
c'est vrai que c'était c'est un destin
absolument tragique je crois qu'il y a
une biographie
une compréhension quoi
qu'elle aurait juste eu besoin de qu'on
la voit telle qu'elle était en fait et
pour comprendre ce qu'elle avait ce
qu'elle avait voulu mais elle a aussi
joué dans deux longs métrages
de Guy Joret et ensuite dans équilibre
de Marion désolé si j'écorche le nom
mais c'est harcèle je crois mais voilà
et puis elle a quand même elle a quand
même publié oui d'autres œuvres donc
elle a vécu
cette fin encore plus tragique c'est
c'est dire qu'elle a été totalement
incomprise pendant sa petite
reconnaissance si on peut dire et c'est
internement à 13 ans mais elle
commençait à avoir du succès
à 20 ans
[Musique]
reconnu dans le monde des écrivains
un petit peu je dirais pas fermé mais en
tout cas elle était très reconnue et on
lui promettait une carrière brillante et
en fait elle s'est enfin sa carrière
s'arrêter du moment où elle s'est
suicidée elle s'est dit bah non en fait
moi je ne veux pas
parler justement de la Shoah avec le
livre
c'est plutôt la création mais aussi la
censure enfin il y a aussi ça dans le
dans le dans le roman vous êtes une
adolescent s'étouffait
c'est des thèmes qui vous tiennent à
cœur
pourquoi comment c'est fait le choix
justement de ce thème c'est parce que
c'est des lectures
on les regroupant vous dites il y a ce
thème là quoi c'est peut-être ça tout
simplement mais en même temps c'est
l'enfance
enfin le thème de l'enfance en Italie
c'est quelque chose enfin dont on parle
de plus en plus l'ouverture de de ce
sujet là de du rapport de l'enfant aux
aux parents et de un peu de
désacralisation de de l'image de du
parent et de ce qu'il peut apporter
c'est un thème qui est devenu plus
populaire
c'est important d'en parler
les recherches que vous menez
actuellement c'est sur quoi alors moi je
fais en mémoire de recherche et de
création littéraire sur la création
d'une oeuvre totale en littérature dans
le sens vagueien en utilisant des
procédés musicaux et picturaux ou en
littérature d'accord
en fait moi je travaille sur le jeu
vidéo
là aussi moi c'est en fait la lecture
d'un jeu vidéo qui s'appelle Alice
retour au pays la folie qui est un jeu
assez violent et assez moralement
difficile à voir
mais voilà ça parle aussi beaucoup du
deuil de la folie donc pure de la
reconstruction personnelle aussi et
comment le personnage avance et c'est
comme ça que que je l'étudie en fait
vidéo on peut en faire mais ça va tout
le monde aussi beaucoup du jeu et de sa
structure en fait comment il est fait
comment il est raconté qu'est-ce qu'on
veut en montrer aussi mais on peut voir
beaucoup d'idées moi je travaille
beaucoup plus sur l'axe psychologique
donc je me suis beaucoup documenté
là-dessus et ça rejoint un petit peu
justement la psychologie que peuvent
avoir les personnages dans certains
livres et dont Valérie Valère pour
comprendre un petit peu pourquoi aussi
elle a vécu ça pourquoi pourquoi il y a
des choses qui se déclenchent ou qui se
résorbent ça dépend
sur la littérature de médiévale
notamment sur les narrateurs dans un
roman médiéval qui s'appelle le roman
des 7 sages de Rome et tout comme tout
comme les filles je fais aussi une
création à côté ou mon but est de
créer un roman qui contient plusieurs
récits qu'on retrouve aussi un petit peu
d'ailleurs dans la plus secrète mémoire
des hommes et où justement le personnage
principal se met en scène dans des
réécritures de récit médiévaux pour
pour
préciser aussi mais j'ai aussi un
travail de création moi qui porte du
coup sur la création d'un jeu vidéo mais
littéraire c'est-à-dire que il y a
beaucoup de phrases en fait ce sont des
choix c'est un petit peu tirer des
livres dont on est le héros en fait
dès que c'est publié
d'accord et puis on se revoit très vite
voilà pour d'autres délicieux si vous
avez des livres coup de cœur donc vous
avez envie de parler ou des gens que
vous des écrivains que vous voulez être
avouer on fait ça avec grand plaisir
merci merci beaucoup à tous les trois
merci beaucoup à tous les trois et à
très vite pour de nouveaux numéros de
Yves livre
[Musique]